Hi, I'm Jen Kovnats, product
manager on the Google Maps API.
There are a million
websites out there
that have a Google map on them.
These have been built using
the JavaScripts Maps API.
They're helping people figure
out where to go for dinner,
show off their
marathon training,
or keep up to date
with the latest
news on natural disasters.
A map is a great tool to
help your users visualize
the world around them.
And the Google
Maps JavaScript API
lets you craft and
mold these maps,
presenting your own data in
beautiful and compelling ways.
Maps can be used just to plot a
single feature or a whole host
of data.
If you plan to include
a map on your website
to display more than a
single feature at a time,
then you might be very
interested in using the Data
Layer in the
JavaScript Maps API.
The Data Layer gives you a
way to structure and visualize
your geographic
data sets and has
built in support for GeoJSON.
Now, let's dive into some demos
that show just how easy it
is to map and work with data
sets using the Data Layer,
as an example of what
you can do yourself.
Say we wanted to build a
map to show how earthquakes
are distributed
across the globe.
We would go over to the United
States Geological Survey's
website and grab a GeoJSON
file containing information
on every earthquake in the
world over the last 24 hours.
It would contain useful
context, like the location
and the magnitude
of each earthquake.
Now, with a data
set of this size,
I'd usually have to
parse the GeoJSON myself,
instantiate a marker
for each earthquake,
and then plot them all
on the map individually.
But using the Data Layer,
I can load and visualize
the data on the map in
just one line of code.
Ta-da!
The beauty of the Data Layer
is that it provides you
the structure to let you handle
your set of data like a set.
You don't have to go through
the hassle of hand-crafting
a version of collections over
and over again just to handle
simple things like
instantiation, iteration,
and the ongoing manipulation
of data-- hence,
the single line of code.
The other thing that it's doing
is loading data onto the map
directly from GeoJSON
at full fidelity.
Let's take a look
at another example
that takes full
advantage of this.
So the next thing I
wanted to do is not just
see where the earthquakes
were but also get
a sense of their size.
This was really easy to do by
setting a simple styling rule.
It basically goes,
hey, Data Layer,
make each point into a
circle where the radius
scales with the
magnitude of each quake.
And it just did it.
I didn't have to iterate
through all the features myself.
Instead, I was able to set
the style declaratively.
This makes my code really clean.
The other thing
that's happening here
is that the Data Layer still
contains the properties
that the original
GeoJSON file came with.
Prior to the Data
Layer, the minute
you would load
data onto a map, it
was reduced to just
what you could see.
You'd have features, their
icons, styles, the location,
maybe some content
for the Info window.
But things in the
real world usually
have so many other properties.
This is really valuable
pieces of data,
and you might want to
use them in creating
how your map looks and feels.
Let's take a moment to jump into
the wonderful world of GeoJSON.
GeoJSON is great to work with.
There are a lot of formats
out there for geographic data.
Some of the biggies are
KML, Shapefiles, GeoRSS,
and GeoJSON.
Personally, I like
working with GeoJSON
because it's so easy to read and
edit and just mentally parse.
It's an open standard
that's emerged
as a favorite for
sharing and collaborating
on geographic data online.
Now, if you're
familiar with GeoJSON,
then the structure of GeoJSON
should be pretty easy to grok.
Notice that you have a set
of features, each of which
is a geometry-- this can be
points, lines, and polygons--
and an arbitrary
set of properties.
For me, it's really
in these properties
that make the combination of
GeoJSON and the Data Layer
super powerful.
When we first loaded
the earthquakes' GeoJSON
file on the map, these
properties were preserved.
So in the last example,
that magnitude information
for each earthquake was
actually loaded and used
in the map to size
the circle icons.
It wasn't just thrown away.
So jumping back to the
demo, another thing
I wanted to point out is that
the beauty of the declarative
styling approach
is it's really easy
to set a number of
style rules at once.
All you have to do
is add another rule.
Again, in this case, we're
setting the size in addition
to the color.
My code is really clean.
The Data Layer also
makes combining data
from a few different
sources really easy
and can be used for
any kind of geometry.
Let's look at another
demo to show this off.
So in this map, we wanted to do
a visual analysis of education
levels across the United States.
So first, we loaded
the geometries
for each state in the US from
Google Maps Engine via its API,
and it returns GeoJSON.
Using the Data Layer, we could
draw these polygons on the map.
Then we loaded the
US Census Bureau data
on high school education
levels by state.
By mixing these two
sources of information,
we were able to color
our states based
on their levels of
high school education.
And what's really nice is that
because the Data Layer is drawn
in the client, we
can make it dynamic
and interactive by adding
lovely hover effects.
You should try this yourself.
It's worth pointing out too that
while GeoJSON is really cool,
you can also create Data
Layers manually and add data
to them programmatically,
regardless of what format
the data started in.
You might want this if you like
the sound of handling your data
sets as objects and
if you want to do
declarative styling on them.
The Data Layer is
a developer's tool.
It's designed to make your code
cleaner and your life easier.
So if you're creating a
map to show a data set,
the magic of the
Data Layer is going
to give you consistent structure
and hooks for your data,
unlocking things like
declarative styling, semantics
of the data load right in the
map, by way of properties,
enabling you to use this
information in crafting
the map, and native
GeoJSON support,
which makes loading a data set
ridiculously fast and easy.
Take a look at the Data Layer
documentation link to here
to get started.
One of our teammates
wrote a great walk-through
of the US Census demo.
The code for all the rest of
the demos can be found here.
And do take a look at
GeoJSON.io, a website that
lets you generate GeoJSON
on the fly with just
a couple simple drawing tools.
Thanks for listening.
Check us out on Google+, or
Tweet at us if you have a cool
project that uses
the Data Layer.
We would love to see it.
Cheers.